مقطع حديثكم مثل ثواني بس يعطيكم الف
عافيه انتم بتعملوا هون بشكل انتم متطوعين
جميع كم عددكم اولا اخي نحن من عشره من
عشر اشخاص 15 شخص ثاني يوم صار الزلزال
فجمعنا حالنا يعني كنا بالريحانيه
الريحانيه
والقريه سجلنا عليهم
فما يعني ردوا لنا خبر فجينا منا لحالنا
في سيارتنا جزاه الله خير انا علمت انه
انتم يعني انتم جئتم لهذا المبنى لانه في
عدد كبير من الجثيمين
خرجنا حوالي 30 شخص ويوم الاثنين المضى
بعد 8 ايام طالعنا امراه عايشه بفضل الله
عز وجل هذا التوفيق يوم كم جثتي طلعته لحد
هاي اللحظه
حاولت 11 جسه نعم ولكن الله يرحمهم طيب
قديش عندكم معلوماتي تبقى عدد من الجثث
داخل المبنى هذا ما في مبنى الا تحترم منه
اقل شيء عشر اقل شيء هذا المبنى امبارح
نحن صرنا يومين بهاي المنطقه هون لكن قبل
كنا عند جامع فاتح عن جامع فاتح
بينهم من بين هذه الجثمين طفل صح انا
شاهدته
اشخاص هون ثلاث وفي ثلاث اطفال
طفلين نعم الله يرحمه اللهم امين في حدا
بيساعدكم بعطيكم دعم يعني انتم معداتكم
المهدي ما في دعم اي دعم النحاس
اقوى هاي كي يعني اسهل لنا بالشغل لكن ما
حدا رد لنا خبر الحمد لله نحن عندنا خبره
من ايام سوريا يعني
توفيق من الله توكلنا على الله نعم ونعم
بالله ونعم بالله طيب بدي اسالك سؤال
الفرق الانقاذ انا شفتها على الساعه سته
تتوقف سته مساء انتم بتتوقفوا ولا شو لو
كان في جهد ليل ونهار نحنا نستمر هذه
ارواح ما في شيء اغلى من الارواح يعني
ستستمرون انتم تستمر ليل ونهار والله اقسم
بالله مستعد ليله اخرج اي نفس
خصوصا انه انتم تشتموا اكيد الرائحه يعني
ارجو منكم جميعا اخذ الحيطه والحذر لانه
الاسباب لكن لا يضر ولا ينفع الى الله عز
وجل طبعا بس خشيت الام تعرف هاي الجثمين
نعم نعم
من يضر هو الله طبعا يعطيكم الف عافيه
ويعني جهودكم جباره صراحه اتمنى كنا يكون
معنا عداد مثلا على الكهرباء اقوى من هيك
يكون اسهل عنها اسهل لنا في صعوبه
باستخراج يعني
المهدي ماذا ستعمل امام مثلا مقص الحديد
الكهرباء مقص الكهرباء فنحن الحمد لله
يدوي شغلكم يدوي الحمد لله يعني ياخر شوي
هذا اكيد لا شك وسبحان مع هذا الشيخ بفضل
الله عز وجل يسهل لنا توفيق من الله عز
وجل ليس منا يعطيكم الصحه والعافيه الا
بالله الله يعطيكم الصحه والعافيه انا
طبعا من ورائي في هذه الصوره هذا الشاب
المنهار فقد 21 شخص من اسرته نايف يعني هو
يبكي على هذه الجثمين التي التي تعرف
اليها وتعرف على هذه
يعني
هو مشهد صعب بصراحه يعني
الله يرحم افراد اسره
وفعلا يعني الشباب تعمل بشكل متطوع لساعات
طويله ومستمره بادوات بسيطه جدا يعني
يسابقون الزمن لانه خشيت انتشار الامراض
طبعا انا اتحدث اليك وللاسف الشديد انه
رائحه الموت في كل مكان نعم طيب